for every idea that you come up with how
many of them are what you consider bad
ideas and you throw them away well I I
feel like I never really throw an idea
away
um an idea will either be
just not ready yet
um or it's it's not enough to be its own
thing I'm gonna have to put this aside
and this might be a piece of something
else later on
um yeah there's just tons of ideas that
you you work out in your head and you
think is that something is that you know
could I and then when it comes to the
point where now I can't make that gel I
just I just keep it somewhere in the
back of my head behind my left kidney
somewhere and you know be five years
later I'll be working on something and
I'll just think ah subplot you know uh
villain you know and also I must say you
know I've been making a lot of short
films now
and so it's been a great treasure troll
for me to go back to some of these ideas
that I try to develop as feature films
or a TV series and I never could really
figure out a way to sustain them for two
hours or for five years but there's
still good solid little ideas
and I thought ah this would be a great
10 minute little movie
and so I've had a lot of success in that
way with just taking this an idea from
you know 15 years ago
uh that now and then if you know you you
modernize it and uh you know suddenly uh
Breathe new life into it so it's not
just the same thing but uh ideas to me
are gold and and I never really throw
them away they're always there
so going back to your friend who bless
his heart wanted to read these
screenwriting books but then said well
what ideas do I come up with it sounds
like for you that's never been a problem
and in fact there's so many it's just
how much time do I have yeah it is
frustrating uh you know there's some of
these I want to do uh you haven't I have
an idea for a new novel
um but that's an incredible undertaking
you know to write a novel and your
scripts I write scripts pretty quickly
once I get the idea and I I feel like
it's formed I can actually write the
script pretty fast
but uh it's frustrating because a novel
I know I was going to devote a year to
that and
um it's hard to put everything else
aside you know to do that but it's a
strong idea and I'm desperate to do it
so uh there are there's tons of ideas
that uh that's also where the short
films help me because I can I can
develop them quickly execute them
quickly and see them done in front of an
audience you know fairly quickly
um but there and I guess it's a good
thing ultimately but it's frustrating
that I just feel like I'll never be able
to tell all those stories that I want to
tell because you know
only live so long
does it become easier to come up with
good ideas the longer you're doing this
the longer you've been creative
I don't think so
um
I don't think it gets easier or harder
necessarily uh the question always is
you get an idea and then you know how to
grow it uh is it really strong enough to
sustain an audience's interest to be
worthy of an audience giving two hours
of their time to watch it
or an hour or whatever it is or 10
minutes
in the case of my short films
um but I don't think you know it to me
it's always been uh yeah the ideas come
but the the forming of those ideas into
a cohesive story is difficult and always
has been I think probably for me always
will be
uh you know it's so Envy as writers I
know showrunners I know people like
Stephen King who seem to be able to just
come up with an idea fully formed and
just get out there and do it and it's a
much slower process for me even though
once the ideas formed I could go very
quickly but it just takes a while for me
to really
get the depth I want and the complexity
that I want in this story and it's it's
the most difficult part of writing for
me because it's really starting from
nothing
and so I stand there at my desk and it's
like the blinking cursor and I've got
this basic idea
but now I've got to just create the
Beats beat by beat by beat and what's
going to happen
and it's horrible for me it's a horrible
process takes me a really long time and
my friends like it because I tend to be
in touch with them a lot because oh I
haven't spoken to bill in a while I
better call Bill rather than actually
concerning his work
but once I start to get the ideas and
the ideas flow and I understand now okay
this is what the story is here's the
ending
uh here's the three acts uh once that
happens then I can really get to high
gear and then I really enjoy it because
now I know what I'm doing I know what
I'm working with it's like having the
frame of a house done rather than
looking at a blank air and trying to
figure out how you're going to build
this house and what's going to hold the
wood up and what's going to hold the
roof up
now the the frame is there and now I can
do the plumbing and electricity and I
can get the siding on and and put the
windows in uh and and then it's fun for
me and then I just go really fast I
write scripts you know really really
fast the first drafts anyway and then it
takes a long time to rewrite them as we
spoke about earlier
and you stand when you write I do yes I
understand like Hemingway
he did yeah huh I thought it was just
the medium well I mean but you do get
more energy standing you know yes the
standing desk when you sit it really I
don't I mean there are times when you
know take a break and sit but right
standing you really the blood's flowing
and I've come to just love it and I
really rely on it now and I find that if
I'm really trying to puzzle out
a plot hole or something really
spongy that I can't get I will sometimes
sit and in my office at home I'm lucky
enough to have this like window seat
and so I'll just go sit there for a
little while and try to think it think
it through and then I'll get something
and I'm back to the desk and you know
but standing gives me a lot more energy
and and I really really like it
I think you've said as a filmmaker at
times you've tended to feel a little bit
in a vacuum with the creative process
can you explain yeah I think it's always
a bit of a danger
um to be you get so caught up in the
process of making a film uh and it it
consumes so much of your life your
energy and your relationships that you
can become so focused on that you're not
open anymore to what's going on you know
around it
um and it's just it's just a dangerous
thing and not only for the actual
process of filmmaking but just in your
life as a filmmaker and it's again
something that the second time I've
mentioned Los Angeles and maybe not the
best way so I don't mean to be piling up
on Los Angeles but uh during the time
like I've lived out here
um
in various stages of my life
and what I've always felt at the times
I've lived here is that the film
business Show Business can just so
easily take over all of your all of your
senses it's everywhere you look you know
it's every billboard everything you see
around you everyone around you is
writing a script you go to Starbucks
there's 10 000 people there writing uh
in fact one years ago One news station
put a reporter in front of the Village
Theater in Westwood
and everybody walked by just said How's
your script coming
I'm like everybody oh my third act so
you know I mean everybody had an answer
for it so
um I do think that for me the advantage
of living in a place like New York
is that I'm exposed whether I like it or
not to every aspect of life every other
profession you know uh where I live in
New York my neighbors an engineer
another neighbor is a lawyer
um a guy down a block is a plumber and
you know they get a kick out of what I
do but they're not like overly impressed
by it you know she's like it's oh yeah
that's fun that must be fun I don't know
um but it helps keep you grounded I
think and out of that vacuum because
that's where creativity dies and that's
where I feel like you start to in your
storytelling you start to reference
things that are not real things from
show business or things from other
movies or other TV if you're not exposed
enough to what's happening in life uh
you know you can be a little narrow I
think
you had mentioned old Hollywood and your
love for that there's a book about how
Marilyn Monroe left La for a while and
went to New York oh really yeah and so
they they put a wig on her a dark wig
they put her on a plane I guess she I
don't know if she was out of her
contract or she wanted out but so things
weren't good in Hollywood so she wanted
to go to New York and they took her to
the closest place which was Connecticut
which they thought was New York but and
so she stayed there but then eventually
made her way to New York City and for a
brief time just felt very uh free and
and was able to you know start working
on projects but then sadly came back to
LA but interesting just just wanted out
of that same bubble yeah well that's
smart it's a smart thing to do and I
think that's why many actors choose to
live if not in New York but but outside
of Hollywood you know whatever that
means today but um you know they go by a
ranch in Montana they'll go you know and
I think that's helpful for their process
to to be in touch with real life and
real people especially for an actor you
know
um so I admire that I do